[Música]
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con
afganistán vive jornadas claves e
históricas se finalizaron 20 años de
guerra en el país luego de que el último
avión de eeuu partiera desde el
aeropuerto de kabul poniendo fin a un
conflicto bélico que se cobró la vida de
casi 2.500 soldados estadounidenses y
unos 240 mil afganos los talibanes ya
tienen el control total del país bajo lo
que denominaron el comienzo de la
independencia para analizar este tema
nos acompaña a carolina sancho ella es
doctora en conflictos seguridad y
solidaridad y magíster en ciencia
política bienvenida a france 24 y
comienzo preguntándole cuáles son los
principales desafíos que enfrenta ahora
el grupo talibán teniendo en cuenta que
no tienen los apoyos declarados en la
comunidad internacional
muy buenos días
gracias por esta invitación
hay aspectos bastante importantes que es
necesario enfrentar en afganistán como
es tal como indica el titular en
pantalla una importante crisis económica
y social una crisis económica que se ha
visto agravada por un largo periodo de
enfrentamiento armado
y en lo más de corto plazo tenemos una
gran importante crisis de confianza que
se ha manifestado en el país por ejemplo
con una salida masiva a sacar dinero a
los bancos lo cual ha dejado muchos
cajeros automáticos sin dinero y ha
obligado a la autoridad a limitar el
retiro de dinero por parte de los
ciudadanos además hay muchos que ya hace
meses no reciben su sueldo y necesitan
desesperadamente obtener recursos para
poder alimentar a sus familias eso lo
podemos señalar en términos micro
económicos pero también hay un punto
bastante importante y es el tema
macroeconómico hay aproximadamente unos
3.000 millones de dólares que están
bloqueados por parte de eeuu a la espera
de que el gobierno talibán dé señales de
que va a cumplir sus compromisos en
términos de
permitirle el ingreso de ayuda
humanitaria
[Música]
permitir el funcionamiento del
aeropuerto para que pueda producirse
esta y respetar los derechos humanos de
las personas de acuerdo a lo que se ha
solicitado desde la comunidad
internacional y muy especialmente en
términos de lo que se ha planteado en la
resolución 25 no desde el 3 del consejo
de seguridad de naciones unidas pero muy
especialmente y un aspecto que es de
principal importancia para eeuu que dice
relación con que afganistán no sea un
lugar desde donde pueda operar el
terrorismo internacional y en primer
lugar afectar los intereses nacionales
de eeuu es todo de todas maneras lo que
usted me dice pues no estaba garantizado
para nada y eso lo tenemos claro desde
los reportes que hemos hecho pero 20
años de guerra si dejan un talibán mucho
más fortalecido rápidamente está mejor
armado que hace dos décadas como se
explica esto
muy buen punto el que señala a lo largo
de 20 años no al mirar desde una
perspectiva de 20 años la salida de con
la salida de eeuu este talibán queda
fortalecido inclusive con armas que los
mismos estados unidos han dejado ahí ya
sea porque se las entregaron a lo que
eran las fuerzas armadas del gobierno
del gobierno de afganistán que estados
unidos apoyaba y que fueron robadas o
fueron entregadas por fueron robadas por
los talibanes al ejército de afganistán
o el mismo ejército las entregó porque
simplemente él decidió no enfrentarse
con los talibanes y sus soldados dejaron
las armas y huyeron en ese sentido
entonces hay un poder bélico superior
hoy día en manos de los talibanes y eso
genera una preocupación importante de
qué uso puede hacerse de este en una
lógica de que efectivamente no cumplan
sus compromisos los compromisos a los
que se les han visitado
internacionalmente pero ojo también
puede ser mirado positivamente en
términos de que si con estas armas
logran tener un control del territorio
nacional enfrentar
a grupos que están generando atentados
terroristas y se tener el control de la
violencia
en esa zona del territorio garantizando
de que es va a ser un país que va a
respetar los compromisos internacionales
pues mire yo le agradezco mucho por su
análisis ya nos quedamos sin tiempo y
seguiremos cubriendo el avance de las
noticias en afganistán gracias a ustedes
y gracias a nuestros televidentes nos
vemos más adelante sigan en france24
[Música]